was there ever any um discussion with uh
dolphin glock about when they did dumb
and dumber because didn't you guys do it
first
yeah we did it first
it was just kind of like i guess maybe
great minds think alike or
chalk it up oh no i feel like bro the
[ __ ] was going so hard they heard that
[ __ ]
that's fair
yeah i always felt like that recipes dog
too i'm a big fan of heads
you guys got three of them right three
of three of them at this point yeah they
was on number two they probably got
three dead i don't know we never know
different spelling though i believe yeah
different spelling
but i mean don't give a rock they helped
us a lot too
with them doing that they helped us a
lot dude and that showed us how like
true with fan base we really would
how much unreleased music do you and rio
have right now
enough
like did you like
it you're in a position where you knew
he was going in so i'm sure like
precautions were taken like look we're
gonna [ __ ] make sure during this time
there's plenty of music to come out
me and rio got some [ __ ] in store for
you
did you guys shoot a bunch of videos too
before you went in like we gotta like
run these like run the visuals up and
then maybe just
strategically drop them throughout the
next couple of years honestly
no
and
the reason why is bros doing so much in
the last couple months all right i want
to focus when even on me and him no more
right
if the [ __ ] was [ __ ] do as much as you
can
oh
you're getting this bread together
making sure you know what i'm saying oh
it's making making the smartest
decisions in within this time
we're saying i don't say we could have
hey we should have i'm gonna put it like
that but and that's what happens
music was recorded my baby was doing so
much my [ __ ] like literally i don't
know i never seen nobody worth that
thing like this [ __ ] bro
that's crazy i'm somebody motivate me
man he's damn near me the way
i'm watching him man and then run around
this [ __ ] like chicken cut up but he
made dogs [ __ ] he made sure everything
was taken care of everything was before
yeah you know what i'm saying so that's
what that was down there the main focus
bro get your [ __ ] we gotta get
everything under control before you you
know what i'm saying
this music [ __ ] time is with us bro
y'all gonna get music from us until we
decided not to make music no more
that ain't you feeling me